let's take that right yeah so my body my
choice the two weeks before i'm due can
i can i get because it's earth can i get
an abortion because it's my body my
choice i mean yeah obviously really
so you you think it's possible like the
woman can do that well i'm asking if you
think it should okay like if you ask me
if it should doesn't hold it in a
subject because that's it that's like
morality now that i think like you're
saying like if is it right is it wrong
like that's not that's not for me to say
you know because first of all i'm not
even a woman so i don't understand this
i don't understand that situation like i
haven't been pregnant you know having a
kid my body knowing if it's alive or not
i don't know any of that stuff but like
um
like it's possible she can get an
abortion whether she should or not like
i don't i don't know it's not for me to
say really and truly i'm saying should
it be legal i don't know you know i
really don't know i mean that's what
laws probably should be legal i guess
like up to birth a girl can get an
abortion like it should be legal that a
person can make a choice on like if they
want to take a pill but whether it's
right or wrong i don't know about that
well it wouldn't be taking a pill so you
know abortion surgical abortions are
after like i don't know one two months
where they pull the baby's limbs off one
by one crush the skull and then vacuum
it out question what they crush the
skull
so so what they do so if i was to get an
abortion two weeks before the baby like
it would be fully formed basically and
they could pull the limbs out one by one
crush the skull and vacuum it out and
then they put the baby back together on
the table to make sure they got all the
pieces well i'll say yeah like in this
case you need humanity like you need
humanity because the thing is you need
to be sensitive to the life to be able
to see if it's going through pain yeah
like you need to be like it's not
something that you can take to the law
to the court because it's something that
you have still within within you like if
you can feel like the child is going
through pain like it's kind of inhuman
to do that to make someone go through
that pain but i don't know i don't know
the science as well so i'm kind of
ignorant when it comes to this subject
no it's okay i'm not trying to get you
in like a gotcha i'm just curious
because i hear that a lot in my body my
choice but if that's the case like if
we're going to use that logic it would
have to be legal up to birth because
it's in their body
and that doesn't most people that i talk
to would agree that doesn't make sense
so then the question is where where do
we draw the line i say we draw the line
like once we know like if let's say for
example the baby is alive and it can
feel the pain
then like um i would say like in my in
my humble opinion
that you know the human thing would do
to like let that child live a life but
at the same time like you know most
people are kind of insensitized so they
wouldn't even be able to feel it anyways
i think so
well and that's the thing
it's not conclusive like scientists
don't don't know when they feel pain
it's not there's not there's not
conflict there's gynecologists that say
like three months there's gynecologists
that say six weeks four weeks and so
it's not necessarily conclusive so in my
end like if we don't know shouldn't we
err on the side of caution i don't know
i can't answer these questions honestly
i think i need to enlighten myself a bit
more yeah i know it's okay not
everyone's really looked into it but if
you ever
like look up an actual abortion
procedure i think it would actually a
lot of people would change their mind if
they saw what it looked like yeah yeah
i'll say like the last thing i'll say
right is just that people should make a
choice and what they feel is right deep
inside themselves
you know and if they feel like that baby
is alive and it you know deserves to
live then that's what they should do
but if they feel like you know like
making the baby come alive it's going to
be bad for the baby
then maybe that's what they should do
instead but you know it's down to the
person on how sensitive sensitive they
are to the life within them and um
yeah i'll just leave it at that because
i don't really know anything else really
intriguing like i need to educate myself
a bit more on this okay well thank you
so much for coming on g
um yeah i want to give a shout out to a
miracle safe soil where we're just
raising awareness for an environmental
concern where mother earth she's dying
and she's um you know getting worse and
worse every year so we want to like
slowly decrease the chemicals and
increase organic content in the soil so
that we can make sure the future
generation of kids have something to eat
so it's safesource.org and you know if
we get enough people together we can
elect a government that's going to say
you know what let's think about
long-term sustainability let's think
about 10 years 20 years 30 years for the
next generation of kids to make sure you
know everyone has well-being okay you
know well thank you so much i appreciate
it
have a nice day yeah have a good one
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
sure
it makes it quite cold the whole aspect
of it being a contract but then i can
see the logic behind it the logic is
strong
do you think the more our society has
focused on loved as opposed to duty that
marriage has broken down because of that
yeah because it's
well yeah i mean
i guess i mean my parents are like well
my my dad's past my mum's 76 and you
hear the story and a lot of it's duty
like making things work they eventually
they got divorced and then they came
back together
but i think a lot of people's versions
of love is more lust
or infatuation and it's going to pass
there's not a case of right we've been
brought together we've got we've built
something together let's make this last
it's like oh i'm tired of you now i'm
fed up with this
let's keep it moving but you've got now
you brought kids into the world it's due
love is overtaken duty by a long shot i
think disney has played a lot into it
because people think it's like supposed
to be this electric like fairy tale sort
of thing
yeah i mean i can't i can't i can't
speak for obviously i can't speak for
women yeah of course but you know
for guys i think because obviously
obviously i feel guys are more logic
based quite often and they're kind of a
bit more pragmatic
whereas you know we're talking to lots
of different women over time it does
feel they're looking for that spark and
then you're like look
you're talking about you're on a family
you're looking for a spark but
you're 39
[Laughter]
well
you know i mean i mean i don't you know
i don't want to be horrible i mean
there's there's the chance she loves a
young person's game
i think love and not being loving
is a human condition but the whole
but the living in that realm of
possibility it it's more practical it's
easier when you're younger
actually i think it's to be to be really
fair when i was younger i didn't have
any idea understanding of it i think now
it's much it's much easier for a guy on
certain levels because you have more
time which for a woman it's when you
know when i was 21 and the girl was like
really hustling me like what do you want
to do where you were going i think i
would be young like relax because now i
can look back at it and go
[ __ ] she had a point because for her her
window her time her window time is very
very short i mean 90 percent of her eggs
are gone by 30. yeah i heard that i've
had that conversation with
a girl she was like 32-33
and she got it but you know as a guy
most girls don't really want to have
that conversation yeah you know women
leave seventy to eighty percent of the
time in marriages and ninety percent if
they're college educated so it's really
not the men that are breaking up the
home it's the women yeah i kind of knew
that already and i've seen it already i
mean because i used to work quite a lot
for uh in the nightlife industry so i've
people i've known for like over years
and years i've seen their patterns and
it does make me question because there's
not many guys who are like yeah jumping
up and down wanting like i really need
to get married and have this romantic
wedding and everything else i've always
what i've always thought about and then
they concede and they do it because they
feel that's that's what they need to
access this girl and give her what she
wants and then she gets bored
or all the guys are stuck in situations
where
it's just barren because the
attraction's gone yeah
well thank you so much for
for sitting down um you're kind of red
pill i don't know if you you watch red
pill content yes a little bit a little
bit
um bits and pieces i mean it's
i think to be honest some of it is just
it's just like what was never really
allowed to be said if you're if you've
got some experience
but you know
i always kind of um
look to still maintain some compassion
well thank you very much appreciate it